if you think that rishi sunak had a
better show can you put your hand up now
ladies and gentlemen please after the
win
the wobble
team sunak hoped last night's show of
hands in his favor at the end of the sky
news battle for number 10 might mark a
turning point for the underdog
but instead rishi sunak was faced with a
video released by the new statesman
where he told tory members he diverted
money from poorer city regions to places
like tunbridge wells i managed to start
changing the funding formulas to make
sure that areas like this
are getting the funding that they
deserve because we inherited a bunch of
formulas from the labour party that
shoved all the funding into deprived
urban areas
in a visit to eastbourne today ahead of
another round of members only hustings
it was a good night actually fantastic
rishi sunak was unable to dwell on last
night's showing for long i was making
the point that deprivation exists right
across our country and needs to be
addressed and that's why we need to make
sure our funding formulas recognize that
and people who need help and extra
investment aren't just limited to big
urban areas
it was here in number 11 downing street
that as chancellor rishi sunak built up
a standing among the public and the tory
party
with furlough the eaton to help out
scheme and cost of living support team
sunak were hoping to brand him as the
candidate with a proven track record of
being on the same side as the british
people
but questions remain about his wealth
and his background and what's so
damaging about those comments revealed
today is that for some tory members
about to cast their vote it will confirm
suspicions that he just doesn't
understand the lives of an increasing
number of struggling britons
meeting investors in the city of london
today as part of a drive to slash
regulations liz trusts framing herself
as the only candidate for the realistic
means of getting money into people's
pockets the most important thing
is getting the economy going so we avoid
a recession and the businesses usual
policies aren't working
we need to do more and that's why i'm
determined to reform the economy and
keep taxes low
but how much can she offer some fiscal
experts fearing the consequences of
acting too drastically too quickly what
the candidates really need to focus on
is growth over the medium term if they
try to prevent a recession now by
pouring money into the economy there's a
real chance they make things worse
because they might pour fuel on the fire
of inflation
for all the efforts on this contest
delivering what conservative party
members want to hear focusing too much
on one part of the country at the
expense of another will be a costly
mistake
the eventual winner will have to make
sure that they back britain as a whole
if their future is to be guaranteed
mari aurora sky news westminster